The next thing we're going to cover is serialization and saving games.
Whilst this sounds like a pretty substantial topic in terms of you on your game,
normally the same system can get quite sizable, depending on the kind of game you're making,
but actually in terms of what you need to get a save system implemented in Unreal is actually pretty limited.
First off, what actually is save games, I think most of the people will know this,
but it gives us the ability to save the state that we define of the game,
close the game, reboot it, and players are able to resume from where they last left off.
The implementation is very much down to the kind of game that you're making.
If you're making a roguelike, you may not try and save the actual active world at the moment,
but maybe you save the unlocks that they have.
If you're saving something like a huge open-world RPG,
maybe you need to save where they are, the AIs around them, and it gets much more complicated.
In Unreal, really what it provides us is the ability to save games to a file
and load them back in, and then what we do beyond that is kind of up to us.
You can have multiple forms of save class, which is useful even within a single project,
because a very typical implementation might have you having a settings save file,
which is kind of global to all users, and then a per user save file.
For player one, you have got three slots and you have three different saves
that you can save in each of those independently.
As well as that, obviously it supports multiple save game files, like I already mentioned,
and the save game isn't restricted to C++.
You can have a Blueprint-only project and you can still implement all of this functionality.
So there's actual steps for having a project that actually has a save game
and you can save it and load it.
First thing you need to do is actually make your save game class, which inherits from save game.
Then you just choose what data that's going to store,
then you really need to define two key pieces of data, really one, which is your save slot name.
It depends on the platform you're on.
Save game index can or cannot be relevant.
Actually by default on Windows, the save game, the user index it's called,
actually isn't relevant, but it can apply for other platforms.
Then we just use the create save game object, create that save object,
put the data that we want to save into that object, and then save it.
We can do that synchronously or asynchronously.
Let's actually just quickly go through a demonstration of this.
In our example project, I've just made a class for us to reference.
It's as simple as this.
You make a Blueprint that inherits from the save game class.
Blueprint, save game.
It's that simple.
The one I've already made, very easy.
It inherits from the save game and I've just got this one float in it,
which is just some float that we want to save.
What can be a little bit confusing is you'll see in Unreal,
when you have a variable selected and you go into the advanced section,
we have this save game flag.
This doesn't magically make this get saved.
It's not really doing a huge amount for it.
It's not going to put it into your save file.
In fact, this save data will save even if that isn't ticked.
What this save game actually does is marking it for this variable for serialization.
When you're trying to save a U object or a struct,
and you're trying to serialize that object or struct
down into something that can be written into your save file,
that is what that flag is there to mark.
It's to say that when I try and serialize this object,
I'm interested, this piece of data is relevant.
This is like a serialization helper that just means
you don't have to manually put in every single variable for each class.
Unreal will find it for you to say,
oh, this is relevant to saving and loading.
If you mark this off, it's more about object serialization.
Either way, we've got this variable in our save game.
If I went to our level blueprint,
I've just done a little bit of a setup here.
Essentially, on our begin play,
we're going to try loading two different save files.
As I said, on Windows, the user index isn't relevant.
In all of these, I've just left user index is zero.
To define the two different save files,
instead, I've got this, I've actually customized the save slot name.
So we've got some default name, which is just example save slot.
And then we are just appending a value to it.
So this is to represent multiple save slots.
So the name plus one and the name plus two.
And we're trying to load both of those.
If it loads, we read out the value, that some save float value,
and we'll just print that out and set that as our save game.
And we do the same thing for number two,
but print out that it was from number two and set that as save two.
And then I've just got this, I'm just binding to these button keys.
When I press one, we randomize that number,
print out what the number was,
and save that game with that value written into it.
And same for two, but just for our second slot.
So if I, I'm just going to clear out my save files.
So to kind of demonstrate this, I'll come back to this in a second.
But if I go and play a game, you see no save game found for one or two.
Now if I hit one, that says it's saving the value is 3.8.
Now if we just remember that, if I stop, quit play in editor and play again,
you'll say it's found found no save game two,
but save game one, the value saved is 3.8.
And so if I do two, it's now 4.8.
And if I regenerate one, so the save file already exists,
but I'm just overwriting that data.
So 4.8 and 9.4, if I stop and play again,
we'll see 4.8 and 9.4 in those two different slots.
So it's that simple.
You just put data in the save object,
you create the save object, you push that data into it,
and then you save it.
And yeah, the load functions work in the same way.
So the only other thing is about where this data is actually saved.
You might have just, if you were paying close attention,
then you might have noticed me jumping into a folder there
just to delete the previous saves.
You can see by default, when you're in an editor project,
it will get whatever project you're in.
So in this case, example five, five project in the saved folder,
you can see we've got a save games folder,
and that's where they'll get created.
And these names will just match whatever you're feeding into that save game function call.
So just this slot name is what that literally the name of that file will be.
That being said, on a fully built version of your game,
it won't necessarily be, I think in a development build,
it will be next to your executable.
But in a shipping version of your game,
it will actually go into AppData on Windows at least.
I can't comment about Mac, but just worth bearing that in mind.
If you're struggling to find your direct people to your save games
in a shipping build of the game,
it's probably somewhere in your AppData, like AppData local,
whatever your game name is, something like that.
But that's essentially all you need to do to get a project saving.
The kind of last thing just to mention
is the fact that there are a couple of these key functions.
We've already covered some of them, creating the save game object,
saving the games to slot and loading the games to slot.
But there are also asynchronous variations of these things.
Both of these are available in blueprint and C++.
And it is despite the fact that the demonstration I just gave
did actually utilize synchronous saving and loading just for the sake of speed.
It is obviously strongly encouraged
that you probably lean on the asynchronous functionality,
especially if your game has larger save slots for loading and saving,
just because otherwise your game is going to freeze up and hitch.
And obviously that's not desirable.
So the asynchronous versions of these functions
are the ones that we encourage,
but otherwise it works in exactly the same way.